in fact I see more possibilities in
adversity than in say lying on satin
pillows so in that respect I guess I am
an optimist
I think there's reason for optimism I
think there's reason for at least for
personal optimism I don't know if the
world is gonna survive but I'm gonna go
as long as my heart beats your book
should have political consequences
although you know where demand reform
this book should surely be a best-seller
in New York City at least telling us
what most of us really had no idea about
is what the life of a homeless person is
like nowhere do you mourn the existence
of the homeless but anybody for reading
the book is bound to say oh my god
something's got to be done about this
yeah and the wall there is you know
that's a tough one it decide you know
I've never seen you know man
tries to be sociologists all the times
but the truth is you know if you look
around we really suck at it so I don't
know if there's I don't know if there's
anything I mean to be done about what
eliminating it moving these people
getting them out of our face feeding
everybody I don't know what's to be done
about it except to find what your
relationship is to it I think that's the
only work I don't think the work is to
eliminate what offends our sense of what
should be or who we are I think the work
is to find a way to a relationship to it
just when you pass some money on the
street what is your relationship with
them I mean how are you a human being to
them
I mean and beyond that I think anything
being on that is [ __ ] we used to
sell Street News and he started writing
for Street News and then I guess he
became probably their top writer were
you editor-in-chief finally I was
editor-in-chief when they they decided
they we couldn't pay any more salaries
and everybody else left yeah but you got
to sleep on the couch in the office
asleep on the couch in the office yes
which was a good deal but I I confess I
haven't read street news the way I
should have were their editorials in
there about what should be done about
the homeless there were some they were
off in some and and there was never any
accord because you know it's like trying
to and to push a waterbed flat you know
you push it here and it pops up over
there and I found you know there I have
a prior history of sociology and in
raising coming up black in the 60s and
here at 60 years later and billions of
dollars in lots of speeches and
countless laws and walls on here in
these days whoops women mistake you know
so I you know I really don't have a lot
of faith in in installing a perfect
society or even a pro-forma solution to
any kind of social problems very very
much so I uh but I admit when I was in
those days I wrote a couple of
begrudging you know I wish so until we
get off of his that is this if I wish
people would do that type editorials but
for me the fun stuff was that when I
could just riff on my own just go on
about what's inside of my head that was
an amazing thing to be on the streets
and not be heard you know as Joe
homeless but just to be able to have a
place where I can just riff from my own
mind that's a very amazing remarkable
and wonderful place to be in the middle
of
in the 1990s or in the 80s it was a
wonderful place to be it was I would
have I was rich in that respect the
average person who had a home didn't
have that so was it was uh it was a
wonderful forum for me editorials er
editorials I always find her just the
agenda that's attached to events and
it's and I got very tired of writing
them I don't suppose I wrote many of
them all that well but the stuff the
stuff I like was writing about people
places and things that first-person
stuff but I sure love that couch do you
do you run into old friends who are
still on the street yeah I do
and do you impulse to rescue them or to
do something fun not at all well you're
not a very nice guy no actually I'm not
great for sumptuous you know I barely
rescued myself and and you know one
thing I noticed from being a being on
the street is that you know looking the
other way is that all of us are really
everybody in this room is really just
sort of groping their way around in life
we grab one of the things that tell us
we got it all figured out but I bet if I
asked to show our hands of how many
people just had a little as bit of doubt
that they don't have it all figured out
I bet you everybody would raise their
hand so in in in that respect
it's kind of presumptuous too I think to
try to try to know how you can save the
next person at least for me this may
surprise a lot of people for them to
hear me say but it's it's an honest
answer I don't really I'm still working
on you know saving myself it's gonna be
a lifetime job
so I don't know if I can really get to
the point I have time or the wherewithal
to save you the next guy I don't know
what's right for you I wouldn't presume
to tell you I know well you gave us a
wonderful gift in the process of
building you soul I must say thank you
it's really a swell book and I I
compared him to Jack London because are
you gonna read the part where he
realizes he can write no we don't have
that far time yeah well tell the story
leave where were you when when you
discovered you really could write yeah
that story's been Mike really I really
wish I could wiggle out of that one
because that that's been hammered into
the ground but I was I was just sitting
there with a pencil I'll say that much
and a pencil that I was using as a drug
implement to push the screens in my pipe
and one day I didn't have any drugs and
I decided to use it as a pencil I'm sort
of smart that way because I was gonna
use that pencil some way or another that
day and and I started writing and the
remarkable thing was it was five hours
later before I stopped that was really
remarkable I don't think I did anything
for five hours in a row during that time
except try to get high and then try to
outrun and then or try to outrun the
effects of getting high I don't think
there was anything else I did with that
much concentration it was a remarkable
moment like I identified him with Jack
London because
Jack London I had the same very
experience he hit bottom and he was
working in a steam laundry and he
decided God there's something better
than this and he started writing and it
turned out he could really do it ask us
a question I think this is a good place
to read a little bit from each of the
books the first is a passage from Grand
Central winter it's one of those bright
glorious Indian summer days gold dust
streaming through the front windows of
the street news editorial office tree
tops across 9th Avenue swaying gently in
the breeze and I'm standing hunched over
my desk teeth clenched cursing muttering
at the printer one of those worthless
low-end Panasonic dot matrix jobs with a
temperament all its own sitting in
frozen silence red error light blinking
dumbly back at me refusing to print so
much as a digit and what keeps running
through my mind is why am I doing this
but I know why I did it to myself I went
and got myself an honest job not that I
was looking I had an income I sold
papers as many and for as long as my
needs required I didn't really feel I
was missing anything out of life by
being on the street either at least not
anything that could be had by paycheck
and I wasn't really interested in being
employed simply for the sake of it what
I wanted was to do something worth a bit
of satisfaction as well as a buck
something that might make a difference I
imagined that as a writer I might help
light up Street News's pages and that
this might help it emerge from its
doldrums I was wrong of course not that
I'm complaining exactly I enjoy working
with words that part of the job delivers
a certain satisfaction but as for any of
my work making a real difference in the
larger scheme of things as for having
any impact on the growing public
resentment toward homeless people I've
had to climb down from that high horse
from time quake I have taught creative
writing during my 73 years on automatic
pilot rerun or not I did at first at the
University of Iowa in 1965 after that
came Harvard and then the City College
of New York I don't do it anymore I
taught how to be sociable with ink on
paper I told my students that when they
were writing they should be good dates
on blind dates should show strangers
good times alternatively they should run
really nice whorehouses come one come on
although they were in fact working in
perfect solitude I said I expected them
to do this with nothing but
idiosyncratic arrangements in horizontal
lines of 26 phonetics signals ten
numbers and maybe eight punctuation
marks because it wasn't anything that
hadn't been done before in 1996 with
movies and TV doing such good jobs of
holding the attention of literate santi
illiterates alike I have to question the
value of my very strange when you think
about it Charm School there is this
attempted seductions with nothing but
words on paper are so cheap for would-be
ink-stained on wands of cleopatra's they
don't have to get a bankable actor or
actress to commit to the project and
then a bankable director and so on and
then raise millions and millions of
buckareenies from manic-depressive
experts on what most people want still
in all why bother well here's my answer
and many people need desperately to
receive this message I feel and think
much as you do
care about many of the things you care
about although most people don't care
about them you are not alone
so that leads to the question of why do
we do what we do whether writing or
anything else
well it's since you've billed me as the
new jacket one day and I'll have to say
it beats working in a laundry but you
know I it's it's a for me it the reason
I do it is it's the first thing I
completely chose to do on my own
I try it on my own made up myself and
and kind of found that I could do
alright at it that's that's that's
almost 90% of it and also I guess
there's 10% of the fact that that it
that it's I find it's very good for me
so then at least maybe a half a percent
where I hope it will be good for you
guys I don't mean to be stingy but but
um I found that when I try and do it the
other way that I overdo it and then it's
good for no one well there's a swell
book it's out of print now maybe seven
stories will bring it out again it's
called the writer and psychoanalysis by
a man who's now dead named Edmund
burglar and he said he claimed he had
treated more poor writers than and he
was practicing in New York of course he
treated more writers than than anybody
else in his field and he said that
writers were fortunate in order that
they were able to treat their neuroses
everyday by writing and he said as soon
as the writer was blocked this was
catastrophic because the writer would
start to and to go to pieces and so I I
sent a piece for Harper's or a letter I
wrote the Harper's about the death of
the novel that people would continue to
write novels or maybe short stories
because they would discover
they are treating their own neuroses and
I have said about practice of the arts
that practicing any art is painting
music dance whatever literature is it's
not a way to make a money or to become
famous it's a way to make your soul grow
so you should do it anyway and and what
Bill Gates is saying now and how much
were they offering to kill Salman
Rushdie okay anybody here a million
dollars who killed Bill Gates but let's
see the mind he's he's saying you know
hey don't worry about making your soul
crow there's also your new program is
that let your computer grow year after
year after year
that's cheating people out of the
experience of becoming you know I saw a
book being written written about in one
of the papers today and in the book was
about how to but hold on the power be
powerful and and a deface of it you know
it seems like you know go go go 90s book
when you think about it some of the
advice he was he was giving people in
the book was like totally anti human it
was like make people depend on you you
know this people buy books to learn how
to do this yeah it said one of his
thing's was don't say much people will
think you're smart you know
I wondered why you wrote the book she's
all wet when you're shooting Bill Gates
if your bullet misses I hope it hits
this guy we have another passage this
one from Grand Central winter afterwards
we'll ask another question this
describes an encounter at the central
booking holding his cell early that
evening the cell gates clang dopin in
the sea oh uh sure din a thin bare
chested Spanish kid wearing Hospital
green pajama bottoms splattered with
crimson his arms were suave rich wrist
to elbow and bandages and he was
grinning ear to ear they had to keep my
shirt for evidence he announced to no
one in particular holding his damaged
arms aloft like trophies and then
without prompting he launched with
relish into his war story he and his
crew were doing a burglary cop surprised
them in the middle of it he he took a
bullet and went on trying to escape this
was a matter of particular pride and
he'd done in the other arm scrambling
over razor wire so they had to patch him
up at Bellevue before they could book
him Oh in all it was a Hollywood worthy
night out for a Restless team they tell
me I'm a career criminal he got
encouraged at ball everyone was duly
impressed I was both captivated and
unsettled by his Moxie though I never
let on I was puffing on a cigarette
contemplating how much of it to leave
for the guy who had begged this short
from me when I saw the kid move for the
Jersey boy I liked that rope home boy he
said leaning his face into jerseys let
me get that chain something in his hand
was was pressing against Jersey's
jugular incorrigible but this was just
the thing to break the monotony of
sitting on your butt awaiting the
pleasure of the court the holding cells
sprang to life a circle of inmates
formed too deep around Jersey in the kit
if we were going to be treated to a
throwdown they were determined to keep
the CIO's at bay for as long as possible
but Jersey had had enough fisticuffs for
one night apparently he didn't give up
the chain but he did yell for help
I heard Keys rattle in the gate a second
later correction officers were elbowing
their way through the human blockade but
the kid who could have easily just
ditched the Shiv remained oblivious to
them he just stood there
menacing Jersey while the guards broke
through and grabbed him and as they
hauled him off to book him on an
additional charge caught a glimpse of
his face his smirk was wider than ever
most of us in this cell could expect to
walk we knew if we just bite it our time
and let the criminal justice grind take
its course
we could get back to whatever it was we
were doing with a minimum of hassle the
kid though knew he wasn't going anywhere
he was a career criminal he also knew
that with his good looks youth and
Dominion of size it was better to go
inside with that don't give a [ __ ] bad
ass rap preceding him in that respect he
was for all of his bravado only being
practical and buying in on the cheap for
all that when it comes to justice the
kind that gets you locked up is
different from the kind you find inside
personally I would like to see all the
judges and district attorneys made to do
time not for the crimes they commit from
the bench where they commit those out of
ignorance which is precisely why time in
prison should be part of their
qualifications so that they might come
to know what they don't know they don't
know let them sit faceless and despised
in the holding cells
let them be run through the ringer of
their process until the wind has been
wrung out of their self-righteousness
and let them stumble on the wisdom every
two-bit con knows instinctively that
real justice is always poetic so the
question
the question is there is the adventure
of life and there is our need to
understand it what might be the
relationship between those two events
for each of you Wow well I'm so kind of
flummoxed here if you write better than
I do
well I'll take a shot at that big the
big the big questions like that make me
nervous
because you know you know it took quite
a while to write this book you know it's
all packaged meats out there and you
know so I don't want to say anything
that it's gonna [ __ ] it up you know
right now what people I've got
everybody's confidence from the book but
there was for me there was a very very
very big relationship between the what
did you call it the adventure adventure
and the events the adventure and it was
and I did look at it at the the the time
on the street as an adventure I looked
at it that way from the very first day I
said well let's see what happens next
and there's a very big relationship to
it because when I finally came up for
air actually it made a big mistake out
there I don't think the mistake was the
streets I think it was getting myself
trapped all over again it wasn't any
particular thing but at the time I got
myself trapped it was trapped into a
certain cycle and by the time I think
once I got off the streets I didn't know
what else to do with myself I certainly
didn't want to leap back into this
non-existent thing called the mainstream
and and it was only the book and I think
and and I sat there for a couple of
about a year and a half hoping to finish
it and so the relationship was that
I couldn't finish it until I resolved a
few things I mean I I couldn't
I certainly despised just putting down
exposition telling the details and an
October 4th I did this and then that
happened I can't I can't stand doing
that I can't sit down and do that there
are writers who can do that
reporters residual I very well I'd
rather have my teeth grinded than do
that so I had to find reasons to - I had
to find a way to write and reasons to
write it that were interesting to me and
hopefully worth your time because it
never occurred to me than anybody the
working past the bookstore would be
particularly interested in what this
person unknown person named Lee stringer
had to say and then if I was lucky
enough for somebody to happen to pick up
a book and browse through it I wanted to
make sure that that you know they they
felt they've done a good thing and might
even want to continue but so so in out
of that process I found that I couldn't
find the way into any any of the
episodes in the book until I had gotten
ahold of it a little bit till I
understood what it meant to me and not
only want the people around me were
doing but you know why maybe so so
there's a by the end of the of writing
this book I had answered a whole bunch
of questions and I thought that was a
very wonderful thing it was almost
having it published daniel is almost an
afterthought in that respect because
that for me the top of the mountain was
getting to the end answering those
questions for myself
all right well let's cause some more
trouble with the final selection this is
from Time quake a Luddite to the end as
was Kilgore trout as was Ned Ludd the
possibly but not certainly fictitious
workmen who smashed up machinery
supposedly in Leicestershire England at
the beginning of the 19th century I
persist in pecking away at a manual
typewriter that still leaves me
technologically several generations
ahead of william Styron and stephen king
who like trout write with pens on yellow
legal pads i correct my pages with pen
or pencil I've come into Manhattan on
business i telephone a woman who's been
doing my retyping for years and years
now that she doesn't have a computer
either and maybe I should canner she's
moved from the city to a country town I
asked her what the weather is like out
that way I asked if there have been any
unusual birds at her bird feeder
I asked if squirrels have found a way to
get in and so on yes the squirrels have
found a new way to get to the feeder
they can become trapeze artists they
have to she's had back trouble in the
past I asked how her back is she says
her back is okay she asks how my
daughter Lily is I say Lily is okay she
asks how old Lily is now and I say
she'll be 14 in December she says 14 my
gosh my gosh it seems like only
yesterday she was just a little baby I
say I have a few more pages for her to
type and she says good I will have to
mail them to her since she doesn't have
a fax again maybe maybe I should can her
I'm still on the third floor of our
brownstone in the city and we don't have
an elevator so down the stairs I go with
my pages clump at E clump any clump adiy
I get down to the first floor where my
wife has her office her favorite reading
when she was Lily's age was stories
about Nancy Drew with a girl Detective
Nancy Drew is - Jill what Kilgore trout
is to me so Jill says where are you
going I say I am going to buy an
envelope she says you are not a poor
why don't you buy a thousand envelopes
and put them in a closet she thinks
she's being logical she has a computer
she has a fax she has an answering
machine on her telephone so she doesn't
miss any important messages she has a
zero she has all that a tarbush I say
I'll be back real soon out into the
world I go muggers autograph hounds
junkies people with real jobs maybe an
easy lay United Nations functionaries
and diplomats into the news store I go
relatively poor people with lives not
strikingly worth living are lined up to
buy lottery tickets or other crap all
keep their cool they pretend they don't
know I'm a celebrity the store is a ma
and pas joint owned by Hindus
honest-to-god Hindus the woman has a
teeny-weeny ruby between her eyes that's
worth a trip and who needs an envelope
you must remember this a kiss is still a
kiss a sigh as still aside now I know
the Hindus stock of stationery as well
as they do I didn't study anthropology
for nothing I find one nine by twelve
manila envelope without assistants
remembering simultaneously a joke about
the Chicago Cubs baseball team the Cubs
were supposedly moving down to the
Philippine Islands where they would be
renamed the manila folders be a good
joke about the Boston Red Sox - I take
my place at the end of the line chatting
with fellow customers who are buying
something other than lottery tickets the
lottery ticket suckers de corte cated by
hope and numerology may as well be
victims of post time quake apathy you
could run them over with an 18-wheeler
they wouldn't care from the news store I
go one block south to the postal
convenience station where I am secretly
in love with a woman behind the counter
I've already put my pages in the manila
envelope I address it and then I take my
place at the end of another law
line what I need now is postage
yum-yum-yum the woman I loved who is
there
does not know that I love her you want
to talk about poker faces when her eyes
meet mine she might as well be looking
at a cantaloupe
I put the waiting time to good use I
learn about stupid bosses and jobs I'll
never have about parts of the world I
will never see about diseases I hope
I'll never have about different kinds of
dogs people have owned and so on by
means of a computer no I do it by means
of the lost art of conversation I at
last have my envelope weighed and
stamped by the only woman in the whole
world who could make me sincerely happy
with her I wouldn't have to fake it I go
home I have had one heck of a good time
listen we are here on earth to fart
around don't let anybody tell you any
different
which leads to the last question which
is do you agree that there is a place
beyond the text that readers are
experiencing when they read you and if
so what is the place beyond the words
that you write well as I've said our
audience has to be performers and so
they have brought themselves they have
done work in order to decode these
messages on the page and so they because
they are involved they become our
partners they've brought themselves to
it that's the extra dimension about
which we know nothing but it's
delightful to know that they can't bring
themselves to it they have to or they
can't read I don't know I don't know
quite how I could say I can tell it in a
story maybe because I sense there's
another dimension but I can't quite nail
it down but I can tell this story which
may get near there it was during while I
was on the street one day I was walking
down 42nd Street between 8th and 9th
Avenue it's a middle of the afternoon it
was kind of a grey day and what I had
coming towards me was sort of a marching
army people just slogging along in the
middle of the day nobody was smiling
everybody was walking going to wherever
they were going or coming from wherever
they'd been and and and if you really
looked at it they were all suffering in
a sense they were all it was just a
burden to go through what was their day
and as I got near the end of the corner
I hear the tinkle of a piano and I see
above the heads all these gray heads
this one pink sort of melon shaped thing
going like this like this and I got
nearer nearer the corner and I found out
it was a preacher from Jersey he'd set
up these huge speakers on the end of
42nd Street which I called God's corner
well and he was playing this very bright
very modern gospel music in the middle
of this very gray very sad time of day
and he was just keep leaping up and down
with joy they just had no reason for it
he just set up these speakers and he was
dancing in the streets and he was
smiling and he was bouncing around and
people were walking by and as I came
abreast of him that the Sun broke
through the clouds it was almost
pathetic and the light burst on in its
attorney his pink face iridescent and I
said to myself god no that's where I
want to be why this guy is and and that
you know that's the kind of dimension
I'd like to I can't I'd like to be less
direct but more just people that just
sort of read and say well you know
that's where I'd like to be as simple as
that
thank you
I did I just want to add that virtually
every writer I know would rather be a
musician because music gives pleasure as
we never can this is music is the most
pleasurable and magical thing we can
experience and I'm I'm honorary
president of the American Humanist
Association but I simultaneously say
that music is the proof of the existence
of God you play an instrument by the way
I play clarinet badly and I really had
no keyboard whatsoever and I tell you
our president there's no bad mean
reitman he's not bad I've heard him play
that nobody has brought that in his
defense that man can really blow so to
speak sorry
what do you think is the relationship
say between the Kurt Vonnegut and the
least string or is sitting here and the
one that the reader encounters in a book
Wow I don't know well I do I would one
nice thing about our trade is compared
with poetry or with painting and
possibly with music is we don't envy
each other is Whistler James McNeill
Whistler the painter said if you wish to
see Envy go among the painters but
novelists do not envy each other
if a writer succeeds makes a lot of
money that makes all other writers happy
and so it's a most agreeable field we're
in and I think in a sense we are
veterans of the same battle and we know
what the hell it was like is is you know
we're not like Duke Wayne who was never
in the battle but we know what that
fight is like and we respect each other
for making it and anyone who has
finished a book whether the thing has
been published or not whether the thing
is any good or not is a colleague of
ours for me um I read traits books when
I years ago I read them just I never
wanted to be trendy so I read them just
after everybody else read them and then
I was sorry I'd waited so long but when
I heard that Curt liked my book it was
it was like meeting a comrade I mean it
was it was to have another writer speak
favorably about your work is just a
great feeling because it is kind of a
it's not a science we're not making
porcelain or not you know cutting out so
to bite before is it's it's it's kind of
crazy stuff to just sit in a room and
click away at a with my case er if
you'll forgive me a Mac for you know for
eight or nine hours there's a very
unnatural thing to do when it's there's
no one there to tell you whether what
you're doing right or wrong you just
sort of got a it's a very scary thing
for me I mean there's been a year or so
doing that and and the real ferret fear
is that you look look back and said gee
I wasted a year doing nothing so in in
the midst of that loneliness to have
another writer say well you know that
it alright is is a great thing in and
but in that respect I feel like hurts a
comrade for life and and and then have
and then reading and rereading some of
his stuff and reading some of his
interviews and and hearing his comments
it wasn't just a we live I thought I
thought we were real comrades because
there is something that a lot of writers
I've read about who talked about writing
especially modern-day writers such as
Kurt in James Baldwin is over someone
I've read in Ralph Ellison and and
Nelson Algren is is there is something
we all do that similar way we sort of
futz about saying what that is what did
I you know I can I can hear it
resonating in in the words of all these
people so so that's about it
I sort of overworked overworked that
little thought but thank you for
listening always like Jacqueline Susann
who was I considered her a colleague and
and critics wouldn't like me that person
was pretentious it's myself to this do
like Jacqueline Susann but I did like
her very much and she wrote with utter
sincerity or people would not have
bought these books as you cannot fool a
reading audience and she was sincere
with all her storytelling and a very
nice thing happened between Jacqueline
Susann and myself before we met valley
of the dolls I think it was was number
one on the bestseller list for I don't
know two years something like that
entertained a lot of people and I
finally knocked her off with breakfasted
champions which was very briefly number
one on the bestseller
and I got a note from this woman who was
a stranger at that time she said a lot
is long isn't it had to be someone I'm
glad it was you that grateful you spoke
of Lee before as a born writer do you
feel that you were a born writer as well
I I don't know yes I think so because
some people are born musician some
people are born chess players or
whatever and in school I could some
people could run a lot faster than I
could I could write better than most
people good so yes I got lucky i till
heller and i recently confessed
something was shameful for two writers
to confess to each other we'd both had
relatively happy childhoods which is
which is no way for a writer to begin
what about yours none of my business
um you know what was happy to me it was
happy to me I was I was angry but I was
happy at the same time if I don't know
they understand that I wasn't satisfied
maybe that that has an impact but you
know I tried to write when I was younger
a few times but it it was never about
anything
I mean I I like to play with words I
certainly like to read a lot but it was
never about anything that I knew
anything about I was always about you
know spies and planting trips to outer
space and things I didn't know anything
about and it had nothing to do with any
characters so I get about you know I get
a great first paragraph and then I have
a trunk full of first paragraph
somewhere that may might might become a
book one day if I if I get lucky you
want some tips on writing
well you know I like that I had fun
discovery I have a lot of fun bumping
into discover this isn't it's a joy of
discovery for me I kind of would not
like to know what I'm doing like I had a
lot of fun trying this to figure out how
I'm gonna fill up these pages and then
convinced that I was I'm not and then
bingo something happens it is it's like
shake it it's like shaking hands with
God for a second it's really a great
great payoff for the hours you sit
around wondering if you can do what
you're trying to do
once again the proof of God I think
sculptors of course feel that somebody
else is using their hands that they
couldn't possibly be doing this anyway
the arts are so good to those who
practice them yeah I wouldn't ask you
did you ever get now the have you here
anyway I wanted to talk to you and
privately that hasn't happened yet but
there's one question I when they ask you
what is the do you finally get to a
point when you're writing when it's it's
almost like taking vacation well I'll
have to think about that yeah in a way
is I had never thought about that image
before yes I guess so his I feel I'm
lucky as hell as I guess again I can't
really do this somebody else must be
doing this like taking dictation but
again
I've written a hell of a lot of crap had
been published most of it but I would
come to work and write all day or write
for 3-4 hours and this is lousy have you
done that absolutely there's two other
grandsanta winters in the drawer one may
be a good place to end Kurt Vonnegut
leaves during a thank you very much for
coming the book is Grand Central
also thanks to Barnes and Noble and
thank you all
correct